Chris Christie has just visited Ukraine
uh he's visited Ukraine and he's done so
on a mission to bring Ukraine President
Vladimir zielinski some Bon Jovi
memorabilia
John wrote out the lyrics uh to the song
It's My Life which serves as an
inspiration for a lot of the citizens in
in Odessa as they were preparing for the
invasion by the Russians he wrote it out
in his own hands got it framed and I
brought it to president zielinski
presented to him and said that this is
representative of many of the American
people and what they feel about the
cause that's being fought for in Ukraine
and who support Ukrainian people against
Russian barbarism and uh we got a good
laugh over it about two guys from New
Jersey trying to be supportive of what's
happening over uh in Ukraine for the
Ukrainian people and so I I was happy to
do that and to be able to show him that
there's lots of folks over here in fact
hundreds of millions of Americans who
believe that the Ukrainian cause is just
there's also lots of folks over in Kiev
there's also lots of folks
from America who seem to be flying in
and out of Ukraine to hang out with
zelinski and take photos for glossy
magazines and do long interviews and
bring him memorabilia from 1980s rock
stars and they seem to be doing it
pretty easily
for a war-torn country
that it would seem to undercut the
argument that Ukraine is in this state
of Total War it's the most perilous
moment for the for Europe in the last 70
years when Chris Christie sees fit to
fly in hang out with his buddy have a
few laughs over
look I like Bon Jovi but you know it's
my life it's now or never this is just
not this doesn't seem like a good
good use of War resources and it would
seem to undercut the argument that we
need to keep sending 10 bazillion
dollars over to Ukraine because it's on
the brink of collapse and we're going to
head into World War III a lot of Tourism
for a war zone
so what's the point of this trip
other than to have a talking point for
Chris Christie on the campaign Trail and
on CNN the point of this trip why would
the former Governor of New Jersey who's
now running for president in a long shot
bid why would he go to Ukraine
especially when Ukraine would seem to be
maybe not according to the liberal media
but would seem to be just according to
the conservatives I talked to not the
most popular issue with the GOP base the
point of that trip
is to signal
to the liberal establishment that a
president Christie would accept the
state department foreign policy
Mike Pence just went over to Ukraine too
to Signal his support for the the state
department policy that he will continue
this war
the point of which I'm not quite certain
and the end point of which I'm not quite
sure when that would be
that's different than say a trump who
says I'll end the war immediately that's
different than a DeSantis who
it's been a little vager on the issue
but he's
broadly signaled that he's in opposition
to continuing to fund this war
in in contrast to Vivek ramaswamy who's
within the top three candidates now same
thing
you're seeing that big split
the GOP Insurgency which says we're
going to upend the foreign policy that
has defined both parties for the last 40
years maybe more than 40 years
the UNA party
and
The Establishment more establishment
leaning people who say no we're not
going to change foreign policy at all
and what's what's crazy about the moment
that we're in right now this populist
moment in the GOP and a little bit for
the Democrats is that the Insurgent part
the Insurgent group the populists who
say we want a totally new foreign policy
those are the guys who are currently
winning the other guys are Chris
Christie when you want to protect
yourself against the machinations not
just of the deep state but deep big Tech
you got to check out expressvpn right
now go to expressvpn.com Knowles Canada
w-l-e-s do you know what big Tech and
big government have in common they're
both big and they both want to silence
any dissenting voices into submission
let's say you're a proud gun owner and
want to talk on social media about the
right to bear arms well chances are that
your post will be flagged by a Content
moderator and you might end up on some
kind of government watch list to fight
back against having your voice censored
I recommend expressvpn the problem with
big Tech is that not only do they
attempt to censor you but they also
track what you're doing online what
you're searching for the videos that you
watch everything you click they can
match your activity to your true
identity using your device's unique IP
address when I use expressvpn they can't
see my IP address at all my identity is
anonymized by a secure VPN server plus
expressvpn encrypts 100 of my internet
data for protection from hackers and
eavesdroppers expressvpn is by far the
best one I've tried it's super easy even
a Luddite like me can do it rated number
one by CNET Business Insider countless
other Tech Publications right now go to
expressvpn.com get three extra months
for free
expresvpn.com Knowles expressvpn.com
Knowles to learn more right now go to
ziprecruiter.com Knowles if you are
hiring you know that it is incredibly
hard to attract top talent with the
current labor market conditions it is
even harder than ever that is why you
want to partner like ZipRecruiter
ZipRecruiter gets it zip recruiter knows
how tough it is right now they've
figured out solutions for the problems
that you are facing try them at
ziprecruiter.com
for free to reach more of the right
people so recruiter posts your job to
100 plus job sites ZipRecruiter smart
technology finds great matches for your
job and unless you invite the most
qualified people to apply their pricing
is very straightforward so you can stick
to your budget with no surprises team up
with a hiring Partners such as
ZipRecruiter that understands what you
need four out of five employers who post
on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day
just go to this exclusive web address to
try ZipRecruiter for free it is
ziprecruiter.com Knowles that is
zippercruiter.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s ZipRecruiter the smartest
way to hire
Americans are done with the war in
Ukraine
The Establishment will constantly tell
us no actually the support for Ukraine
pulls very high in the GOP it's just you
crazy Tucker Carlson Donald Trump Mega
populist conservatives you guys are
Fringe if you think that maybe the
perpetuation of the war in Ukraine is
not a great idea no the the majority of
Americans and the majority of
Republicans
majority of conservatives
the good conservatives they they support
the ongoing war in Ukraine that isn't
true it just isn't true we have a new
survey out that shows it and this is a
survey
that uh
that shows that 1200 adult respondents
in this poll conducted by SSRS among
them 55 percent said Congress should not
approve additional funding to Ukraine
45 supported more funding so
not saying it's 70 30 I'm not saying
it's 80 20. but it's 55 45 it's a clear
majority of Americans and
Democrats are much more likely to
support the war in Ukraine so among
Republicans it's pretty clear
they want to wind down the war in
Ukraine and this marks a reversal of
that CNN poll that was conducted shortly
after Russia invaded in February of 2022
which found that 62 of Americans wanted
the U.S to do more to help Ukraine well
now they're saying No thank you so it
will change depending on how the
question is asked but money talks and Bs
walks and when people are asked should
we continue to send money and therefore
arms and Munitions and all these other
resources to prolong the war to keep the
war in Ukraine going majority of
Americans say no
which we I could have told you before
even with the stupid CNN polls because
the the poll that matters on this issue
is the pull of the GOP Primary and every
top candidate by a long shot is saying
we want to wind down this war boy what a
great clip that was now um
[Applause]
ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel we'll see you next time